so like as we thought about the like
creating the purchasing flow like what
we wanted to do was we wanted to create
an experience that was familiar I like
really made it super optimized for if
you had a product out there to make
people purchase it and for us it was
really important to make it like a clean
purchase experience and so as we thought
about how we wanted to make our purchase
flow uniquely teespring one of the
things wait wait wait you did realize
was that TSP content is very much
targeted and always very much optimized
for people wanting to tow it to their
friends and share it like on all the
different platforms out there and so one
of our thoughts was like how can we make
this like experience what kind of people
are actually purchasing from the page
but at the same time it and encourage
them to share it via email Facebook
Twitter Pinterest and all these other
channels and so that was kind of like
the only other kind of special
optimization layer outside how we did on
the purchase flow but otherwise the
purchase flow kind of i is is is is like
a very like understood thing across
across most ecommerce companies